The American Chestnut tree
was one of the most abundant
and dominant trees
in the Eastern United
States Appalachian chain.
They were gorgeous trees.
It is actually the tree that
inspired the Christmas song
"Chestnuts Roasting On An Open Fire".
It was a very heavily
used resource by people.
In the late 1800s,
people brought Asian
chestnuts to North America
as an ornamental tree, and they
carried with them a disease,
a fungal blight and it infected
native American Chestnut trees
and just wiped them out completely.
Over 99% of the population
was obliterated.
Fast forward nearly 100 years
and a team led by William Powell
at the State University of New York
was able to actually
discover why the blight
kills the Chestnut tree.
And they have produced a
strain of Chestnut trees,
that is 100% resistant
to this fungal blight.
It really shows that there's
no point of no return.
There's potentially no point
you can get where you can't
end up recovering and healing
the damage that's happened.
And that's the hope that biotechnology
brings to conservation.
The UN is issuing a dire
warning on climate change.
Nearly a million species
are at risk of extinction
because of humans.
We are doing irreparable
harm to Earth's biodiversity.
And what is clear is that we're driving
species to extinction.
The human species has driven
the planet's biodiversity
into an unprecedented decline.
The extinction rate is 1000 times higher
than it naturally would be
with as many as one
million species at risk.
Many scientists say we are
in a sixth mass extinction.
The decline in biodiversity
is a crucial issue
that is largely overlooked
in the public consciousness
in terms of how important it really is.
Our existence as humans
is deeply intertwined
with the health and flourishing
of a number of non-human species.
If you destroy the environment,
it's going to turn around and bite back.
We need to radically
rethink our relationship
to the natural world.
We need to understand that
we are a deeply entrenched
part of it, certainly
not separate from it.
This is part of what is
killing other species,
and eventually us too.
Traditional conservation methods alone
are struggling to offset
the speed at which
we're losing species and habitats.
Biotechnologies that have
been developing in the wings
are now offering the hope of
new, if not controversial,
ways of saving endangered species.
Genetic rescue traditionally
has been the practice
of increasing a population's
genetic diversity,
in a way to benefit it.
Usually when the population is exhibiting
some type of problem, like
inbreeding or whatnot.
We're trying to increase genetic diversity
or increase the viability of
the genetics of a population.
Then in that kind of very core definition,
biotechnologies offer a whole
host of ways to do that.
Biotechnology offers
everything from genetic insight
to restoring diversity with cloning
or technologies or doing gene editing,
to aid disease resistance,
all the way to that moonshot
of using all those technologies
to restore something
like a wooly mammoth
or a passenger pigeon.
The process of resurrecting
species like this
is known as de-extinction
and it's one of the more complex
and controversial applications
of this biotechnology.
Because of biotechnology,
we can bring back those kinds of animals.
But of course it is a tedious work to do
but it is not impossible.
De-extinction is a scientific
movement we could say,
an emerging space of researchers
who are trying to use a variety
of different biotechnologies
in order to help recreate
close approximate versions
of extinct species
so that they can create new animals
that mimic extinct species
and can go back out
into the wild spaces where
extinct species used to roam,
and carry out important
ecological roles there
that have disappeared since a
certain species went extinct.
The very first example of de-extinction,
if you call it that, is the bucardo,
which is a Pyrenean Ibex
or kind of a mountain goat.
The last bucardo died in
Spain, it was a single animal,
but they took some cells from
its ear and preserved those.
And years later, they used those cells
to clone a bucardo using a
domestic goat as the surrogate.
So they could create cells,
implant an embryo in the goat
and the goat gave birth to a live Bucardo.
The species was brought back,
only to go extinct again
just 10 minutes later,
due to lung defects.
The 2003 resurrection of the
bucardo remains the closest
that anyone has gotten
to true de-extinction,
at least for now.
In 2017, George Church's
wooly mammoth project
captured the public's imagination
and brought de-extinction
back into conversation.
So de-extinction is
really just a little bit
of hybridization, using ancient DNA
and some modern synthetic
DNA to achieve a goal
of say cold resistance
or pathogen resistance.
Church hopes to adapt the genome
of the wooly mammoths
closest living relative,
the Asian elephant, to include
a number of mammoth traits.
In particular, how to
thrive in the cold climate
of the Arctic.
We are using the tools of paleo genomics,
which is the ability to
actually get DNA sequences
from those extinct species from
100s or 1000s of years ago,
and look at their genetic code,
compare it to their living relatives
and start to understand what
are the unique fragments
of DNA that made them do what they did
in the environment.
Two, there's now something
called gene editing,
which is most famously
done with CRISPR Cas-9.
It's an enzyme and RNA combination,
that basically is a homing
system that allows scientists
to target any region of DNA
in a living cells genome
and make a cut and then
make an edit to that area.
So we could take the hemoglobin gene
in an Asian elephants genome,
and cut it and overwrite
in its place the hemoglobin
a wheel from a wooly
mammoth, which will change
how it bonds oxygen at
different temperatures.
And that's something
that George Church's lab
has already done in
culturing a Petri dish.
So it used to be a big deal
to make one precise change
in the genome of an animal.
We've made 42 changes in pigs.
We now have 2000 adult pigs
that are called three point, version 3.0,
that are used for organ donations.
And that's being tested
now in preclinical trials.
That shows we can do
42 in a cell and a lab,
and then move the nucleus into an egg
and bring it to term all
the way to adulthood.
Thousands of times.
So we wanna do the same
thing in elephants,
which are a little bit bigger than pigs,
little slower but otherwise it should be
a very similar procedure.
While altering the
genome of living animals
like the Asian elephant
could help bring a version
of extinct species back to life,
it could also help to rescue a species
which is itself endangered.
We want something that
has all the advantages
of cold resistance, possibly
resistance to pathogens
like the EEHV virus, that's
almost extinction level
harm to the Asian elephant,
which is an endangered species.
So you can consider it a hybrid
but it also, we can
use synthetic biologies
to say alter tusk length
to avoid poachers.
So there's a number of opportunities here
that is not limited to
de-extinction of genes.
Church wants to re-introduce his hybrids
into the Arctic Tundra,
which he hopes will preserve
an environment that's
crucial to storing carbon.
Science has proven
de-extinction is possible,
and the environmental argument
for doing it is clear,
yet questions still remain.
Doing de-extinction, there's
a whole lot of unknowns.
And especially when you're
trying to think about a species
like a wooly mammoth
that's been gone for thousands of years.
What are the prospects for
being able to put this back
in the appropriate kind of environment.
Does wooly mammoth habitat
even exist anymore?
And if you go for very long extinctions,
the further back you go,
the more uncertainty,
the less we know about the species
and the less likely there
is to be a place for it now.
The technical ability is
outrunning our ability
to think about is this a
sensible or a useful thing to do.
And this is concern that, you know,
if we're dealing with
something as fundamental
as the genetic makeup of species
and thinking about putting
them back out into the wild,
you know, the genie's
out of the bottle a bit.
What does it mean to take the tools
from synthetic biology and merge them
with the more traditional
conservation biologists,
who are losing the game,
as we're, you know,
also losing more species,
can really fruitful combination be born
from this hybridization of knowledge sets.
And indeed it seems to be happening.
There are interesting projects
getting off the ground,
when you bring these two different ways
of looking at nature together,
something that's engineerable
and something that's worth saving.